the eu-us trade pact is up for
discussion at the education youth
culture and sport council in Brussels in
May in parallel with fresh negotiations
on the transatlantic trade and
investment partnership or TTIP EU
ministers will be updated on how
cultural goods and services are being
handled these aspects including
audio-visual works have always enjoyed
different treatment in international
trade negotiations in part to help
guarantee Europe's cultural diversity
but the United States remains keen to
put the issue up for negotiation despite
Europe's red lines in the sport format
ministers are set to encourage EU
countries to develop policies and
programs for eliminating gender
stereotypes and promoting gender
equality in sport this includes the
prevention of gender-based violence and
protecting victims of harassment
meanwhile members will be urged to
ensure that only suitable people work in
sport particularly with minors the
financial crisis has placed an
increasingly heavy burden on countries
organizing and hosting major of sports
competitions in Europe so ministers will
also discuss ways to promote the
economic social and environmental
sustainability of major sports events
the glasgow commonwealth games chief
executive officer will be a guest
speaker in the youth segment ministers
from the presidency trio and
Commissioner vassal you will exchange
views with representatives from youth
organisations the council will also
discuss any you work plan aimed at
developing jobs and learning
opportunities for young people as youth
unemployment rates soar in Europe the
plan is set to run for 18 months and
will be evaluated toward the end of next
year